Harris Jackson has a message for the
tabloids the daughter of the late
Michael Jackson took to Twitter on
Wednesday to shut down reports that
she's made an official statement
regarding the controversial leaving
Neverland documentary everybody wanted
to meet Michael or be with Michael and
then he likes killing Paris called out
one blog that posted quote Paris Jackson
believes her father Michael is innocent
of sex abuse claims the 20 year old
responded quote I actually haven't made
any statements yet especially regarding
how it affects my work life
you guys are reaching a bit at least
this wasn't a disgusting and attacking
article though she followed up the tweet
with another writing y'all take my life
more seriously than I do I was seven
years old Michael asked do you and the
family when I come to Neverland the HBO
documentary details allegations of
sexual abuse against Paris's late father
featuring new interviews with accusers
James safe Chuck and Wade Robson told me
if they ever found out what we were
doing he and I would go to jail for the
rest of our lives in the documentary
safe Chuck and Robson now married adults
with sons of their own claimed they
engaged in sexual relationships with
Jackson that started when both were
underage 10 and 7 years old respectively
secrets will eat you up you feel so
alone I want to be able to speak the
truth
as loud as I had to speak to lie for so
long
through on-camera interviews they recall
how they each first met the music icon
and later became closer to the pop star
since its debut at this year's Sundance
Film Festival leaving Neverland was met
with immediate backlash from Jackson's
family who slammed the production in the
press repeatedly we know our brother
Michael wouldn't do anything like that
and then he waits until after the
passing of Michael ten years later to
come out and state this and he's there
still in court whether with their state
showing him for hundreds of millions of
dollars Paris however hadn't spoken out
about the film this documentary is not
telling the truth
the Jackson estate also filed a one
hundred million dollar lawsuit against
HBO ahead of its premiere calling the
documentary quote unvetted propaganda to
shamelessly exploit an innocent man no
longer here to defend himself
you